[Musik]
ja 1980 eingerückt zur Musik gemeldet
und dann die restlichen 44 Jahre
geblieben jedes Jahr mit junge Leid zu
arbeiten dann die Frühjahrskonzerte die
Zusammenziehungen sprich so wie heute
das Festival und natürlich der die
Auslandsdienst
[Musik]
seit der Jüngere 10 Jahre alt schon seit
20 Jahren und ist bei uns ist der
sogenanntes Familientreffen nicht nur
familienmäßig als die vielen
Freundschaften der tollen Kameraden was
mich begleitet haben die 44 Jahre aber
militärisch ist der militärische Dienst
vorbei das Musizieren aber ich habe noch
privat und da haben wir natürlich viele
Möglichkeiten noch zum Musizieren er
hätte wirklich besonderer Tag es ist
schon Zukunft Familientreffen mein
Bruder ist dabei und speziell hätte der
Papa und hätte sein allerletzten
auftritt und in diesem Moment bei
militärmusikfestival ist natürlich super
also es gefällt mir schon dass er so
einen tollen Abschluss hat in seiner
militärmusikalischen laufbahnkarriere
das Interessante ist dass du so beim
Wirken der einzelnen in und ausländische
Militärmusiken und jede Militärmusik hat
seinen eigenen Stabführer oder
tamburmeister und wenn jeder auf den
schaut dann kannst du eigentlich keine
Probleme geben dann funktioniert das
reibungslos und jedes Glied schließt
Ihnen also die schönsten Ereignisse
nachdem wir erst 11 Jahre dabei bin und
nicht so ein Routine
waren eigentlich nur inländische Sachen
und zwar war das das
militärmusikfestival in St Pölten dann
dürfen mit meinen Saxophon Kollegen 12
Minuten gestern
war schon sehr schön für mich der
heutige Abend wird glaube ich sehr sehr
vielfältig werden ich habe schon in den
ankündigungsvideos gesagt es gibt sehr
viel bunte Musik und auch sehr viel
bunte Soldaten von den Uniformen
angefangen also Daumen des Slowenen
Italiener und so weiter also sehr
farbenprächtig und auch mit den ganzen
Lichteffekten und so weiter wir haben
ein tolles Programm vorbereitet und ich
konnte es wirklich nur jeden empfehlen
und der was dabei war der wird sicher
nicht bereuen